[Musique]
le président du département a remis 600
articles d'équipements de protection
individuelle à la plateforme
territoriale d'appui océan indien
innovation santé cette plateforme
centralise ce type d'équipement qui sera
ensuite distribué aux professionnels de
santé qui interviennent à domicile donc
on va servir après à protéger les
prochaines santé libéraux que sont les
infirmières que sont les médecins les
pharmaciens
tout ce qui manque de protection
actuellement pour assurer les soins à la
réunion je pense au niveau des
infirmiers qui vont suivre des patients
à domicile les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes aussi que mon
quasiment pas eu de masques jusqu'à
maintenant et donc on a des personnes
âgées parce qu'on parle du polydôme ont
ainsi des personnages et non plus de
soin qui s'ankylose qui se raidissent il
faut absolument que les kinés puisse
retourner les aider dans leurs domiciles
des gants des masques des sur blues et
des solutions hydro-alcooliques tout
l'équipement actuellement indispensable
pour soigner les patients
par cette action volontariste le
département intervient au plus près des
réunionnais en difficultés sanitaires et
des soignants qui accomplissent les
soins de proximité le lien social sur le
territoire de la réunion lé département
y participent fortement
et lorsque vous avez des médecins vous
avez tout un corps médical mobilisés
dans la lutte contre coronavirus et bien
le département par son petit geste de ce
matin apporte sa contribution à cet élan
de générosité en mettant des équipements
tels que les masques les blues et
d'autres petits équipements à
disposition de la plateforme
eh bien nous disons au corps médical que
le département est là à vos côtés dans
cette crise mais aussi parce que vous
faites
merci pour votre engagement au service
des réunionnais
[Musique]